Here in Eastern Pennsylvania is a fire that has been burning for 53 years
to the day
It’s gonna be burning for another 250 more
It started simply in 1962 with a dump fire on Memorial Day
it happened all the time, they usually just burned themselves out
but this particular dump fire spread
and it spread to an open coal vein
this fire would start a slow motion disaster
that would consume and destroy the town of Centralia
over the next 50 years
So Centralia sits on a huge vein of anthracite coal
and was founded in the mid 1800s
with the specific purpose of coal mining
...today....
for the first twenty years the fire went largely unaddressed
people didn’t necessarily consider it an emergency
in 1981 everything changed
Valentines Day 1981
Twelve year old Todd Domboski was playing in his grandmothers backyard
when the earth opened up below his feet
“I’d seen smoke and I thought, I didn’t want her, my Grandmother to go over near it
because she’s elderly, and I was worried about her
so I went over to see if it was the mine fire
and when I did I just fell right through
luckily his cousin was there, grabbed him and pulled him out
before he fell into what turned out to be the 150 foot hole that had been created
Centralia went from being an anonymous town with
a little coal fire problem
to being a huge national concern
The question was, what were they going to do about this town
that was on fire
It divided the town in half. Half the people wanted to stay
they wanted to  make it a better place to live, they said it was safe
the other half were basically looking for federal funds to leave
they said “we don’t want to be here”
it got really ugly and finally it ended in a vote
and more than half the town voted to leave
and that was the moment that Centralia truly began unraveling
So in 1984 most of the residents were bought out
and given funds to leave Centralia
In 1992 the town was officially claimed using eminent domain
In 2002 the Postal Service officially revoked the zip code for Centralia
Finally in 2009 the Governor of Pennsylvania began enforcing the eminent domain
trying to make the last few residents, which at this point was down to eleven
leave the town.
But the residents that were still here, didn’t want to go
Their argument was that the coal fire had actually moved
It was headed towards other towns now
and that Centralia’s air quality was back to as good as
or better than it was before the coal fire started
They were allowed to stay. As of 2013 they were given permission to live out their lives here
But when the last 10 resident of Centralia die
the town, officially will cease to exist
Centralia is certainly the most famous example of a coal mine fire
But it’s actually one of 38 active coal mine fires in the state of Pennsylvania
one of hundreds in the US
If you get into India or China we are talking about thousands and thousands of active coal mine fires
and in fact the collective output of carbon monoxide of coal mine fires
may account for as much as one percent of global warming
Much like Chernobyl, Centralia has enough kind of “ruin capital”
It’s a go to I think as a kind of pop cultural reference for
abandoned, disaster.
This is sort of a town gone wrong
the thing that looks the most like a ruin is this abandoned turnpike
there’s not much left, the buildings are basically gone
it looks like a bunch of overgrown lots
slowly turning back into forest
And one day that, you know thats what it will be
It will be some streets through a forest, and no one will think twice about what was here once before